o
[Musik]
jetzt bekommen beim ein video
wir haben jetzt eine basket ab ich hoffe
euch geht's gut irgendwie fand in
letzter zeit immer anders dann also das
ganze wird noch irgendwie so ein
bisschen mehr aus formuliert habe ich
das gefühl etwas gedacht willkommen beim
neuen video leute was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video
ich hoffe euch gibt allen gut ja ja an
sich ist ja nicht von mir dass ihr euch
immer frage wie es euch geht auf jeden
fall würde ich sagen ich hab's antikes
von gelesen ich habe diese idee schon
länger aber ich habe mich nie getraut
das wirklich in die tat umzusetzen ich
habe jetzt aber bei all meinen mut
zusammen genommen und hab mir gedacht
alexej komme das musste jetzt zu machen
fordern bei deiner ganzen zuschauer dazu
auf also die mädels obwohl
wahrscheinlich habe ich auch jungs die
so etwas nutzen wird sich wundern auf
jeden fall sagt ihr mir eure lieblings
die uci produkte zu stecken sollte ich
habe ja früher öfters schon mal so
beautiful duckte von mädchen erraten
aber getestet habe ich ihn nie wirklich
und um ehrlich zu sein
drei leute ich bin nicht schwul das kann
ich direkt mal für die ganzen sagen die
jetzt vielleicht auch das video kommen
und mich nicht kennen ich sonst ankommt
top kommentar dazu über nein bin ich
nicht
mich interessiert das einfach nur und
ich mein wieso sollte man als junger
sowas nich mal testen dürfen deswegen
habe ich mir das witzigste rausgesucht
was ich so von euch bekommen hat das
sind viele sachen nummer eins ist die
anti pickel maske kennt wahrscheinlich
jeder von euch ich habe davon vorher
schon mal gehört wie das jetzt
funktioniert weiß ich nicht moment mal
wie lange müssen das einzige nächtlicher
zehn minuten einwirkzeit die reste der
maske mit einem weichen kosmetiktuch
abnehmen bei bedarf ein- bis zweimal
wöchentlich an wänden habe ich gerade
überhaupt wickel hier so ganz leicht
wozu gefragt soll ich jetzt ein
kosmetiktuch 7 sie gehen einfach davon
aus ihre hat das zuhause oder ist es
hier oben
als zweites haben wir die gesichts
kalkberg streifen da bin ich jetzt echt
mal gespannt
das ding es heißt also das soll ja die
haare entfernen
zu den kassen barth habe ich jetzt nicht
aber auf jeden fall so leicht hier unten
vielleicht hätte das wird so gut tun
danach lockt die suchmaske haut
erholende pflege und antibakterielle
lösung gegen unreinheiten er was das
ergebnis danach sich bestimmt auch die
sonne barbiepuppe wenn es jetzt alles
angemeldet habt und
als letztes das wollen wir natürlich
auch eine milliarden war geschickt
probier bitte mal den pflegenden cream
schaum oder dusche oder sonstwas aus und
ich habe gesagt okay leute probiere ich
mal aus anwendung folge auch die dose
kräftig schütteln beim sprühen aufrecht
halten
dann fliegen in zehn schon gleich mich
auf der haut vorteil und einziehen
lassen
die cremigen schaum löschen sorgt für
reichlich feuchtigkeit und einen samtig
weiches hautgefühl
oh man als ich jetzt sagen das kommt
alles lässt sicher war dann kann ich in
ruhe wie sonst eines babys schlafen
ich würde sagen es fangen wir mit der
anti pickel machte an und das lässt sich
jetzt einfach mal die mutter dann
wirklich zu arbeiten vielleicht sollte
ich die jacke aus ziemlich dass
irgendwas braucht oft verbesserter vfb
sichtbar und 60 prozent also leute ab
gehört das könnt ihr mir ja danach mal
sagen muss ich jetzt alles drauf machen
schreien ich nicht wieso abflussreiniger
oder so hier sind jetzt die beiden
einzigen pickel von mir aber ich also
gut riechen tut das jetzt nicht mehr
ich weiß auch nicht ist das so richtig
wahrscheinlich war ich alles falsch und
merkt nicht wie vor nicht dass ich davon
aus dass sich oder so leute wir sehen
uns in zehn minuten und es brennt
vollgas man irgendwann später so läutete
minuten sind rum
das brennt echt immer noch aber es ist
irgendwie eingezogen ich weiß ja wie das
aussieht das ist ja richtig eklig so
diese bücher die das dann habe ich nicht
deswegen jetzt einfach mal so papier
erkennt man was so leute ich weiß jetzt
echt nicht
hat sich da was verändert die meine haut
zur einer aus oder immer noch wie vorher
es brennt auf dem trittbrett einfach die
ganze zeit okay ich dort nicht würde ich
mal sagen nämlich balea gewicht kalt
wachs greifen und kein fleisch wenn das
einfach nur einer wollen nämlich war
ich bin so blöd jetzt habe ich ihre
pflegetücher pflege-tüv zur
nachbehandlung okay wie funktioniert das
ganze anwendung einen doppelt reibung
zwischen den handflächen zwischen
handflächen reichlich von wärme und an
der kurzen weiter auseinander ziehen
sollte
doch nicht das sind voll viele egal so
das ganze muss ich jetzt erstmal
zwischen meine handflächen erwerben
30 sekunden als erste von stellt zwar
manel guck mal wie folgt ich bin ich
will das büro ist es normal dass man da
von roth wird habe ich sogar 2 kliem
steht einfach mal hierhin und den
anderen klebe ich mal hier im vielleicht
ist das jetzt ein bisschen blöd weiter
vorher diese creme drauf war
aber wir versuchen es einfach mal wie
lange müssen die erzieher dran sein
ich habe keine ahnung davon
scheiße alterskassen ding ist das ding
jetzt was nicht heißt dass nur kurz am
fuß und arbeit vielleicht muss ich das
jonas erhitzen
so leute ist jetzt an dingen die
[Musik]
funktionieren doch ich weiß habe ich
echt ohne scheiß und die ausprobiert
guck mal was über sie gesagt da sind
jetzt einfach keine fahrer mehr alex wie
entwachsen sich gern seine beinhart uhr
läutet den rest von diesem scheiß
wachsen verlosen unter allen die diesen
wieder nach oben geben ganz einfach wir
können nicht bar sowie machen jetzt
weiter mit der suchmaske jetzt bin ich
mal gespannt was denn diese scheiß
dreckiges tuch was über wird und sich
der tägliche was gibt es alles gibt
dürfte wegkommt gelaufene scheiße die
schwarze wanduhr maske mit aktivkohle
fließt kombiniert pflegende und
erklärende eigenschaften eine anlage das
weiche beließ
also an die jungs die so was noch nie
getestet haben muss man nicht erst fühlt
sich extrem eklig an was mach ich jungs
thema kurzem band aufkommen konnte
also was soll das jetzt dringen ich war
kurz zehn minuten werden uns vielleicht
wieder fix in denen steht also an sich
merke ich gar nichts außer dass die
anderen runter rutscht und ich die
wieder hochziehen muss ich heute eine
ziehen zeugt von 1000 euro erbeutet von
water unten
glaub ich nicht er kommt sony wir ziehen
das jetzt darunter alter wie so bin ich
erzogen roth passen dass die drecks
maske du sollst deine haut schön machen
nicht ausschlag schön machen also leute
was würdet ihr sagen will ich jetzt
rainer aus reiner ich musste irgendwie
meine namen rainer denkt manchester und
zu guter letzt lassen wir jetzt schon in
die lose auf ein wirken wenn ich mal
gespannt ob der überhaupt einen wir
kennen mich ja damit schon aus ich würde
sagen jetzt einfach mal so viel das
sollte reichen
das ist viel zu viel haarspray so leute
dass es schnell ein fazit er richtig
schnell ein kleiner leute so viel
erstmal dazu wenn ihr bock habt auch das
zweite folge keine ahnung was man noch
zu testen kann schreibt es auf jeden
fall meine kommentare ich will sagen
weil 15.000 nichts machen was ich komme
gar nicht klar
und kurz dann alle jungs oder so die es
um einen kommentar zu schreiben
wie schwul du benutzt frauen produkte
leute ganz ehrlich wenn dieses ticket
creme oder so wir wirklich helfen sollte
oder mir früher geholfen hätte mit 16
oder so einer zeit wo man halt öfter
artikel hat ganz ehrlich hätte ich voll
aufgenommen so weit an jungs unter euch
also wenn ihr auf pickel oder so
benutzte einfach wissen wie das mal aus
auch wenn eure freunde sagen erhöhte
produkte diese ganzen vorurteile finde
ich eigentlich total nervig deswegen
planung soll doch jeder benutzer will ob
jetzt drauf steht für frauen oder sehr
wichtig er war hier die das ist schon
echt ziemlich weit so sollten wir auf
jeden fall weiß netze und dienste zu
verfassen
und wir sehen uns dann morgen wieder
viele videos
haut rein